[Applause]
whoa ouch Chrissy Teigen and John Legend
have a courtside collision
yeah it all went down during two-way
Wade's final home game of his NBA career
on Tuesday but honestly John and
Chrissy's faces might be one of the
highlights absolutely
the legends also into their faces in NBA
history now this moment is truly epic
Hallie the couple was sitting on the
sidelines at the Miami Heat and
Philadelphia 76ers game Wendy Wade
accidentally crashed into them and
exploded their drinks everywhere take a
look at this
[Applause]
okay but seriously Gabrielle unions face
says it all bracele later the actress
who is Dwayne's wife was spotted
laughing it off with John and Chrissy
before she went back to cheering on her
man like a die-hard fan now moments
after this shot of Dwayne falling on
them went viral Chrissy took to Twitter
sharing the best reaction Kristi
cleverly called the viral photo a
Renaissance painting and responded to a
fan that tweeted a Dwyane Wade so high
team ran into a Chrissy Teigen and
spilled her drink all over her hashtag
Legend Chrissy joked it was an honor
now the ordinary people singer also made
light of being drenched and it seemed
like it wasn't all lost in the collision
still got my drink Gabrielle offered to
make up for the experience on insta
riding a John Legend did not I repeat
did not drop his drink and this is why
we are friends dinners on us in La PS
I'm Chrissy Teigen might be one of my
favorite people on the planet
hashtag last dance I feel like John
showed us his party moves and I am here
for it me too
now the Wayans whole night wasn't
unlucky the NBA stars whole family
stepped out to support him as he led his
team to victory
his daughter Kavya was his cutest fan
cheering him on with mom from her seat
and the proud dad even came over to give
his little girl kisses in between shots
you know I'm dying that's so cute so
cute
et spoke to Gabrielle back in February
where she blushed about how their little
girl takes after her dad so is the talk
of like who does baby take after mommy
or daddy it's she's an actress honey
she's an actress real she's very real
sheep except she sees the camera and
she's like where's my agent we haven't
negotiated this picture so she looks
like dad negotiating skills of mamas
she is definitely her dad's a mini-me
but let's go back to the highlight of
the night way to end things on a bang
doing you could always count on real
friends John and Chrissy to have your
back for all the latest in pop culture
be sure to subscribe to ET and until
next time I'm Holly Stephen and I'm
Courtney teza know
[Applause]
[Music]